what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at Tiff 2022 we are here
with the team behind Roost
congratulations your movie kept me on my
toes and now I'm in an absolute Panic to
talk to you because how are we going to
get into the details without spoiling
I feel bad asking you for this but Amy
can you give us a synopsis of the movie
because everyone out there might not
know what the movie is because it is a
festival debut yes thank you so much
um the movie is about we find this Anna
the character main character on the eve
of her 17th birthday and she's speaking
online to a gentleman that is obviously
not 17 and we sort of bear witness to
what that is for her and also as a
parent and then as the movie progresses
we realize that relationship is more
complicated than we think it is and
twists and turns ensue and
um and it really you know does have to
do with both the the hubris of Youth and
also when you're an adult and you
realize you haven't paid the bills from
your past and the Fallout might be on
your children that's a horror movie part
for me so uh
trying I like that I'm impressed I feel
like that was like a very thorough
understanding of what the movie is but
without Sports It's Magic I feel like I
need to take that when I want to ask
someone spoiler questions and get into
that I don't want to actually have them
flat out ruins yeah
um it's been a little while since your
last feature so why now and why Roost
for the next one you know the writer of
Roost is a playwright out in New York
named Scott organ who I adore and he's a
wonderful writer and he sent me his play
and it was coveted times and I said not
only is this a brilliant play but it
could be a brilliant movie for this
moment and one of the things that I love
about his writing is that he refuses to
demonize people and he sees Humanity
from a very full spectrum perspective
and I felt like that was a really good
antidote to these times when we tend to
be a little polarized in the way we
think about each other and issues
um and for me personally you know I got
to a place in my life where I felt like
my family was in a stable place and my
kids were a little bit older and
um I'd been working on some other things
but I love movies and I love
storytelling so um it's time to get back
in the saddle I met this one and it made
it very easy
just for fun because this is where my
mind goes when someone just like broadly
says I love movies what is what is the
movie or the performance you both saw
early on that made you say to yourselves
I have to get into this industry and no
other industry out there
Amy I never told you this because I was
very embarrassed and shy about it but
when I was 11 my dad showed me Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid and it's
been my favorite movie ever since
confessing this on camera right now
we were filming I was like I can't do it
I can't tell her that's awesome I I
think that's wonderful I you know I um
my favorite film when I was little was
singing in the rain and I loved it
because of the Vibrance but it was also
a bit of an indictment on Hollywood and
every all of those Dynamics and
um I I loved all that that brought to
the table and then you know by virtue of
my upbringing I got to see a lot of
different performances and I got to see
you know people that were so Fearless in
their responsibility to bring a
character forth and I thought that
that's kind of an act of both Civil
Disobedience and obedience at the same
time then I thought was really
interesting so part of the reason that I
sit in this chair and will never leave
it I love discussing what storytelling
can bring in some of those respects I
did want to go back to the idea of this
being a play though because one thing
that always has me curious because I
feel like it's a very difficult part of
the adaptation process is how how I
guess do you avoid your movie feeling
like a play because I feel like that's
often a criticism of play adaptations
but then also like what is something
about the screen that brings something
out of the play that the stage could
never it's a great question I love the
language of the camera and I think we
underestimate not only the way in which
a camera can collapse time and space
um but the way that you know humans can
and we are smarter than we give
ourselves credit for we can make logical
leaps between A and B you know we don't
we don't always have to see all the
micro steps and so with camera because
you can afford a point of view it will
help direct your eye the same way that
words will so I think a lot of it is
just distilling
um some of those moments that don't need
the words that can add the camera as
point of view and it makes it a little
easier to pull it out of that sort of
theater setting I never realized that it
was a play until I read the Press oh so
great success in that department thank
you man Grace I want to ask you about
your character so bad I don't want to go
too far though what would you say is the
biggest difference between what you
thought of her and what you thought she
was going to be on screen when you first
signed down when you first booked the
role compared to who she turned out to
be in the final film well I think a lot
of the times with a subject matter
revolving around a teenager especially
being
in a relationship with someone older
they're often
victimized and and they are made smaller
and younger and more mature than they
really are and something that Amy and I
talked about was Anna is
a bit more mature for her age doesn't
excuse her storyline and what happens
but it does bring a more grounding
aspect behind her and a more relatable
aspect to her I think for more ages than
just a teenager she's not bratty or
young the way a lot of teenagers are
depicted nowadays
and she you know she is the product of a
single mom and the kind of symbiotic
relationship that that can be and
sometimes in order to make things work
it has to be a little bit of role
reversal sometimes you're the child
sometimes you're the parent and I think
you know that's a condition that Anna
grew up with very much
and also I mean grace brings to the
table a kind of very quiet confidence
that you know I think Anna really needed
and she had to be smart because we can't
you know we don't want to undermine who
she is we don't want to say oh well the
only the only kid that would would do
this is somebody who's not very clever I
definitely felt what you were describing
in terms of her maturity but I also very
much believe that she was still a
teenager and had that youthfulness to
her so were there any particular scenes
where you were kind of having a tough
time figuring out how to have that shine
through or how much compared to her
maturity in the situation I think Anna
wanting to share her relationship with
her mom is kind of where you see her
younger
self show through a bit more because it
is something she's shy to share and less
confident in with herself yeah and we we
were calibrating this a little bit
because she does go through a bit of a
rite of passage throughout the film so
you have to kind of back up from that
end moment and then you know say okay
well where do we need to start her out
and she loses some of her naivete
throughout so you know it's it was
really kind of a marked calibration and
a lot of that is Scott because he's a
very crafted writer and then it was just
you know piling on all of us and
figuring out how to time that out how
about the mix of genres here that was
something that was very impressively
done it's like every single time I
thought I knew what kind of movie that I
was watching it shifted so was there any
particular moment in the film or any
particular genre that you found most
difficult to work with in that respect
well I am so grateful that there are
these genres to move the motor of the
story along right because I think that
in the course of one day I go through
about 18 different genres in my life you
know and so I just had to ground that in
the fact that it's not actually that
heightened like being a parent is a
horror and suspense and psychological
Thriller and you know drama and comedy
all at once and so I kind of leaned into
that truth and still you know the the
sort of technique of of some of the
genres and of course Bobby Bukowski
who's my DP could also we could talk
okay where where are we at right now you
know what are we trying to say with a
camera in terms of genres so we were you
know and he's such a master I was just
happy to be able to have that dialogue
it's another question that I feel like
it's going to be difficult to specify
one answer to but when I watch uh movies
with these types of situations where
like the viewer needs to know that the
main character is making a bad decision
like you need you almost want to have
that feeling of like no why are you
doing that but at the same time all of
her decisions need to be justified and
believable for the moment were there any
particular decision she makes where it
found felt most difficult for you to
balance that make sure that you were
kind of ticking both boxes in that
respect well I mean I think I tend to
project myself into those moments as a
human being and and if I if I feel like
we don't understand the why then we have
to back up and say we have to we have to
make sure this feels like an authentic
choice and as a parent you know you can
sort of say that parent that comes up to
the door and go do I go in do I not go
in what's the downstream effect of this
you know if I if I hold my fist too
tight they're going to run away if I'm
too loose they're going to be be without
boundaries you know so
um it again it's sort of like that you
just have to sort of get gut check it a
little bit about what would feel like we
can understand that I understand this
character's choices both from my past
and also my present you know both as a
parent and as somebody who went through
some things as a young woman again I
don't want to spoil anything but Grace
was there any particular scene or
decision she makes in the movie that
like you really had to sit with either
for yourself or just talk through
together to really wrap your head around
what the motivation is for her to do a
certain something
I resonated with Anna's story on a very
personal level I have
um similar experiences as her so every
decision she made I was like
she's handling this a little better than
I did I'll give her that but overall I
understood everywhere where she was
coming from where I love talking about
finding the Magic in the moment on set
I'm sure you prepped as much as you
possibly could but was there any
particular scene in the movie where like
you didn't really like feel the power
that it could have until you were on set
working with your scene Partners I think
every scene with Kyle was just Kyle
gallner is so talented so every scene
with him I was like whoa I didn't think
this would be as
um demanding and and
amazing as it could be but he's just so
brilliant that I felt like every scene I
had with him I was like I have to step
up my game
one of my favorite performers he's so I
one day he'll get the credit he deserves
people talk about it it's my fault he's
not here right now don't go do a great
movie and he's gonna blow up and he's
just an incredible person yeah he's uh
he's an incredibly hard-working actor
and you know I came from an acting
background and so I know that your
sparring partner is the thing that is
the key to you being the best you that
you can be and of course you know Grace
was bringing so much to the table that
you want to make sure you're matching
them with somebody that's going to bring
so much to the table so it was really uh
fun to watch it gave me a competition it
was so challenging
Grace whether it was Kyle or anyone else
you get to work with in the movie is
there anyone who came to the table with
a completely different process or
approach to the work that makes you say
that's an interesting technique I'm
going to put it in my back pocket and
try it on a future film
um I think actually with this project we
all worked fairly similarly where we
could run a scene a couple times with
each other and then we would want to go
sit with it ourselves and then come back
together it was very that we had a very
similar rapport with everyone
um so there was there were no challenges
on like
some actors you are very different and
the way you work is very different so
it's kind of hard to work opposite them
because uh they won't reciprocate what
you need and vice versa but on this
production I think it was very
seamless
yeah I think part of that too is that
our prep did involve all of us being
able to sit and really go through the
words and it's a little bit sneaky
because you get to learn a lot as a
director about the mind of each of the
actors and you know and if you feel like
there is a disconnect it's something to
smooth out before you actually have to
get there which um but with these actors
it was great because they were so game
and so available I feel like you can
feel the fact that you took the time to
do that on screen in the finished
product here I'm gonna have to let you
all go soon you know what I have to ask
you about how often are you asking about
stranger things in an effort to not ask
you is Chrissy gonna come back I I am
really curious about the experience
having like that kind of Fame and
notoriety happen so fast and how that
could change your personal goals just in
terms of like you have this new platform
now you have this wider reach and I'm
sure there's going to be a lot more
opportunities coming your way
post-stranger things what are some of
your priorities in terms of the types of
onset environments you want to be on and
the types of stories you want to tell I
think my goals have stayed the same
they're just more in reach now which is
very nice
I I
just love telling stories that people
can relate to and that I can relate to
and I think I get to keep doing that
which
I'm very grateful for but like obviously
Chrissy and Eddie are gonna fight for
good in the upside down next weekend
just wanted to clear that up
um just a couple of fun questions to
kind of get to know you both a little
more first one is what is your must have
on set whether it's like your sides a
particular drink something to pass the
time when you have down time you name it
um I would say probably somebody
following me around and telling me where
my script is because I like to leave it
in really random places all the time uh
you get spoiled also when you come like
when you were an actor because people do
less looks so I like it when people will
do last looks for me as a director like
they're constantly coming up to me being
like honey you have like 16 pencils in
your hair like you need to you need to
get it together yeah
um music and music I think is a big one
because you get to create your own space
when you need it and if you just have to
shut down really you know and kind of go
internal and just use your mind you know
I had an annual playlist you had an Anna
playlist I made everybody do a playlist
for every character I remember you were
like I need you I was like I already
have it yeah I know I love it I love it
so smart what is on that playlist I'd
have to go back and see once I retire a
character I leave their playlist for a
little bit Anna was very into the
Beatles which like I was never a Beatles
fan before but I was like Anna feels
very so I I'm a Beatles fan now solid
choice right there so what do you have
to have with you on probably sides I I
have photographic memories so I don't
really need them but it's like a
security blanket that is so incredibly
impressed how did you discover that you
have a photographic memory um my dad's
dyslexic so it takes him a long time to
learn slides and I would get like 14
pages of sides and read it once and then
I'd be like okay let's go and my dad
would be like no no not fair so
incredibly impressive
um this is a really big question but
it's something that I've started to love
asking for for you what is your favorite
part of the acting process that you love
so much whether it's like rehearsal
finding you know the unexpected magic
that can happen on set you name it but
then also what is your least favorite
part where you've recognized that
there's an opportunity for growth on
future projects and the same for you as
a director
for me my favorite part is I can be very
introverted and very shy and uh
insecure and every character I play I
make much more confident than me much
more secure much more proud of who they
are so I love getting to feel that for
the period of filming
um something I need to grow in is uh
I think being more receptive towards
other people's way of work and notes and
like you were a gem to work with but I
would never say that about you well no
they're delightful the way they were
things I'm like
I resent that but
I'll try it and I work together again
I'll know that look on your face
you're very nice to work with
I love how everyone has a look a buddy
once said to me because we do like a
like a movie talk show he's like when
you don't like what I'm saying you go
like
and I've watched past videos right I do
do that no I think some directors know
it because like I'll just like start
staring blankly at something behind them
I'm like I'm like I need to process this
give me a moment
favorite and least favorite
um
you know it's such a collective you know
you do you don't make movies in a vacuum
and you hand pick the people that come
together with their toolbox to deliver
on the store that you all have decided
to tell together and so when you start
to see that machine start to take off
and you get to go into drive it's really
exciting because you know movies are a
miracle when they actually happen and
all these elements come together and so
when you see that start to happen it's
it's a thrill and I love that part of it
and I love knowing that sometimes you
just have to step back and let people do
their job and they could probably come
up with things that you've never
envisioned as long as you give them the
dignity and respect to do that and that
part of it for me is super fun
um I would say that we still have some
broken financing models to get things
accomplished and it takes me a lot of
deep breathing to not you know kind of
run out and scream in the streets like
our methods of financing our limit to a
lot of people that it shouldn't be
limiting to and it gets really
frustrating and I think a lot of it is
kind of antiquated so I um but I try to
behave
it's a very good answer to that question
I hope a lot of people who have the
power to change that see this and
actually act on it I feel like they're
going to make me let you leave soon I'll
squeeze in one really silly one I just
love asking this question so much
because you both have acting experience
would you rather have to fake sneeze or
fake vomit in a scene
I think I baked vomit in everything I do
that's my goal
um I think a fake vomit would be a lot
more fun there's a lot more things
involved there's like the Preamble and
you know it can be fun when you don't
actually have to vomit anything like in
certain things I I didn't have to vomit
anything in other projects I've had to
do I have to like hold something in my
mouth
never mind I think I'd rather sneeze
I owe I always think sneeze is the
easier thing because it's not as gross
but it seems so like to do a convincing
fake knee is to do a convincing like
fake like basic everyday anything like
convincing fake sneeze convincing
driving convincing wake up fall asleep
that stuff seems like the most
challenging stuff tonight
there's other things that are convincing
to fake too but
all right so we're fake vomit across the
board yes that's all right fake vomit
all right I'm glad we've clarified now
now I can let you go congratulations
thank you so much for swinging by to
everybody out there keep an eye out for
Roost and stay tuned for more Tiff 2022
interviews